doug's with us in tampa hey doug welcome
to the ramsay show
hi mr ramsey i'm dr john i'm a little
nervous
but um here it goes okay um
i met her i met a wonderful woman
a few months ago after moving down here
from pittsburgh
and there's a large gap
in our income where i'm at about 60 000
and she makes about 175 000
has a house that's valued at over four
hundred thousand dollars
she sounds like a wonderful woman
[Laughter]
she is she is and she's listening at
home working
and you know i've been down this road
before
in 2010 met somebody and
married her and nine months later
i was diagnosed with leukemia however
in the meantime we were trying to buy a
house and i had no credit
and in order to get approved for a
mortgage
i had to take out credit cards long
story short
three and a half years later she
divorced me before my cancer treatments
were over
and i i ended up moving into my own
place
wow how can we best help you today doug
well okay well how do i i see a future
with this woman
but i've tried to convince her if she
gives me a hundred thousand dollars i'll
give her
two percent cash back and she says well
i won't have things
but if she's so confused why would she
give you a hundred thousand dollars
well um for credit cards she's she likes
to use credit card stuff oh
you know and i'm saying you know you
talk about that
yeah the metaphor i thought you just met
a girl like hey babe give me a hundred
thousand
yeah that's a problem so okay here's the
thing
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today's money fights and money
problems and
john will tell you and all good phds in
psychology will tell you you're not
really fighting about money
you're really fighting about what's
important to you power control
control life options margins
and so um until you guys can work your
way through this and get on the same
page about money
the relationship is stalled right
and she's not better than you because
she makes more money than you and
you are not better than her because of
fill in the blank y'all got to come at
this at equals who cares who's making
the most money right now right
or what the really what the past is
that's right the past just makes you
want to address it
right which is a good thing but um
if you can agree on your money
principles and on your spending
you are agreeing about your whole
freaking life right because those things
flow around it
and and when you cannot then you know
you're stalled until you can
and so i would recommend you guys jump
in you can jump in and go through ramsey
plus jump in there together and start
taking some of the classes together it
gives you a point of reference to talk
through some of these things
and you know as this goes forward you
may want to do some pre-marriage
counseling that'll get you there as well
don't marry someone that you're not on
the same page with about money